so years ago I was a camp counselor and
I took a group of kids to the san
francisco zoo to see an albino alligator
it was the first time I had ever seen an
albino alligator and it was feeding time
so the albino alligator got really
excited and turned hot pink as the blood
was coursing through his body so me and
all these seven and eight-year-olds were
equally stunned by this insane hot pink
alligator and that is when I began to
become obsessed with albino animals
albinism is a recessive genetic disorder
passed on from parents who give their
offspring two sets of this recessive
gene which inhibits production of
melanin which gives us our color their
offspring then appears white extremely
pale has pale hair pale skin and pale
eyes albinism is rare for three reasons
one it's a recessive trait to albinos in
the wild cannot camouflage they are
really obvious in their surroundings and
therefore are an easy target for
predators 3 albinos that do make it to
reproductive age can't find a mate
because they look funny scientists think
albinism can appear in any vertebrates
so there could be an albino horse a deer
a crow a dolphin a cow white peacocks
are often mistaken for albinos but in
fact they're just white peacocks white
tigers that you may have seen in the
Siegfried and Roy show or at the zoo
those are actually not all by knows
those are white tigers and you would be
able to tell the difference if you saw a
white tiger with no stripes at all
because no melanin means no stripes if
you have no melanin your own albino if
you have a little bit of melanin but not
as much as most people you're in ALB
annoyed and in humans there are two
kinds of albinism one is ocular which
affects just your eyes so if you have
extremely pale blue watery eyes you
should ask for a genetic test and find
out if you are in ocular albino the
other kind is ocular cutaneous which
affects skin hair and eyes so our ocular
system really relies on melanin to help
us see and if you don't have any melon
in you have
vision which is why albinos often have
sight problems and even blindness what
happens when you think about albinos all
the time you come up with amazing ideas
like this one for an all albino zoo just
imagine the gorilla albino the crows
albino the alligators albino all the
albino animals together in one place in
a zoo well obviously this is a great
idea because these animals would not
survive in the wild so we're doing them
a favor by putting them in captivity
where kids can throw peanuts at them
because that's still a better life than
dying immediately from a predator
attacking you when you're a baby so I
think this idea has serious legs and I
think you should all come to caitlin's
albino zoo sometime in the future when i
get the kickstarter project up and
running and i can make it happen
you